we have a number three which is to
receive the report
from the registrar of voters canvas the
returns of the general election held on
november 3rd
2020 and direct the registrar to submit
a copy of the abstract of votes
cast to the nevada secretary of state
within 13 days after the election
pursuant to assembly bill 4.
okay mr gloria thank you good afternoon
for the record joe gloria register our
voters clark county nevada
i'd like to start by thanking a long
list of people
who provided critical support to us this
election season
we couldn't have done what we did
without assistant from so many different
areas and first i'd like to thank the
commissioners for your support
and the resources as we communicated on
what our concerns were you consistently
came through
with what our office needed in order to
carry out this election
so it really means a lot to our
department that you are here for us
also the county manager and her senior
management team
and a long list of agencies and
departments that i hope you'll bear with
me because they all deserve praise
human resources risk management parks
and recreation with all the facilities
that we used in order to provide
voting i.t the cyber security protection
and all of the work that they did to
support we can't provide the process
that we do
efficiently without constant i.t support
so thanks to them
automotive park police for providing
security
metro police for additional security
provided at our facility and also
throughout the early voting
and election day period the city of
north las vegas and their police
department
city of henderson the city of boulder
city and their police department the
city of mesquite and their fire
department
the city of las vegas and the city
marshals all of the owners of the
shopping centers that
let us have polling places on their
property there are many challenges that
come with allowing us
to come in and provide this service
they've provided
support for additional parking
additional security
all throughout the period so thank you
to all of those property owners
the more than 3 400 county residents who
stepped up
to work at the polls during such a
difficult process
with the pandemic going on and the large
number of voters
who showed up to vote my staff at the
election department who i simply cannot
say enough about
sticking it through long hours day after
day without
any days off i simply can't say enough
for the effort that they put forth in
supporting this election
and then most importantly the voters in
clark county
with that i'll go ahead and read the
results of the canvas into the record
and then
answer any questions that you may have
results of the canvas for the 2020
general election november 3rd
twenty the results of the november third
twenty twenty general election were
canvas comparing the computer printout
of ballots counted and the results
thereof with the official ballot
statement
for each of the one thousand one hundred
fifty precincts
utilized in this election of the 974
185 ballots cast in the 1150 precincts
we identified 936 discrepancies
710 were in the mail precincts 121
in the early voting precincts and 105 in
the election day precincts
six voters have been identified who
voted twice in this election
the mail ballot discrepancies represent
issues related to tracking the process
of ballots
moving from signature verification to
manual signature verification
the ballot cure process and counting
board process
the early voting and election day
discrepancies are related to
inadvertent cancelled vote voter
check-ins
reactivated voter cards duplicate
activations
or check-in errors of the 60
109 provisional ballots cast in the
election
57 866 were accepted
and 2243 were rejected
of those that were rejected 115 had
already voted in the election
142 voted in the wrong district or
precinct
eight were not eligible to vote 1925
were not registered to vote
and 53 did not provide adequate proof of
residence or
identification there were no tabulation
errors in the 1150 precincts
and that ends my report
thank you uh mr gloria do anybody have
any questions
uh kirsten brown madam chair thank you
and i'd like to make a motion
understanding that i would welcome
comments and questions from my
colleagues
uh based upon the report of the register
of voters
i would like to make the following
motion that we accept the canvas of the
vote
and certify the election results with
the exception
of county commission district c the
commission has received
individual briefings in the last 24
hours
and to the best of my knowledge some of
the discrepancies outlined by the
register
indicate that those discrepancies
surpassed
the narrow margin of victory in the
district c
race calling into question the validity
of the election results
in just district c i would like to ask
the register as part of my motion to
come back at the next regular
scheduled bcc meeting with options
for a district c resolution
okay uh commissioner jones thank madam
chair and i appreciate my
uh colleague from district c's uh
motion i i would i would suggest that
under
nrs 293.032
our job uh in conducting a canvas
means a review of the election results
by the board of county commissioners
by which any errors within the election
results are officially noted
and the official election results are
declared so
our job in canvassing the vote is not to
ensure that every single ballot has been
double checked and triple checked and
quadruple checked it's simply to note
any election rule any uh errors
within the election results to note them
and uh and the official election results
are declared
um and we are to complete that under nrs
293.387
today the tenth day following the
election in terms of
how to resolve any concerns that are
brought up
that is under nrs 293
designated for a recount in which
the candidate can ask for recount and
under nrs 293.405
the cost of the recount are borne by the
challenging party so i can't support the
motion i think that our job here is to
note any discrepancies i think
that mr gloria has in his canvas noted
any discrepancies
and our job is simply to accept them and
any candidate can challenge them through
the recount process
okay thank you commissioner gibson
thank you madam chair a couple of
questions first um
to our council what um
what is your counsel to us respecting
the things that have just been commented
upon by my colleague
um so which colleague well mr jones
there is some authority for the
proposition that your job here is just
ministerial
that um is not been the custom of the
commission in the past
when there's been discrepancies that
uh make it impossible for the registrar
to say
that the results are totally valid in
the will of the people
so is the motion that mr that
commissioner um
brown offered up something that goes
without or beyond the authority of this
board to
to do i think it's within the authority
and the responsibility
of the board i have a question about the
discrepancies
we've talked about a number of
discrepancies 936 discrepancies
uh county-wide i take it
what is the circumstance respecting
discrepancies
in district c in the district c vote
are there ballots that are district c
ballots where you have found
discrepancies
and what are the nature of the
discrepancies commissioner gibson in my
review i have found
discrepancies that surpass the amount of
the uh
the victory the margin of victory in
commission c specifically
and can you give us a number and then
tell us
give us a sense of what these
discrepancies are
i've identified 139 discrepancies in the
commission sea race
that follow pretty closely to what i
described in the canvas document
basically there
are records that were transferred back
and forth from
different responsibilities within the
mail process
that canceled check-ins things of that
nature that we can't reconcile and so
they very much
or very well could represent a
discrepancy that would affect the
outcome of the election
so the the nature of these discrepancies
is such that you can't just
look at them again or in the context of
a recount
apply them to one candidate or another
you cannot do that
that is correct sir the privacy of the
ballot prevents us from doing anything
with identifying specific ballots
according to a particular voter where
we would have the ability to pull those
out it's not possible
okay for for now i have a couple of
other questions but i'd like to wait
just for a minute
does anybody else have any questions
that they'd like
answered um
can i share sick of them
i'm still not clear so you're saying
that
that
900 people or this district over 100
people
show they have voted but you don't have
actual vote counts for that
or the vote count will not change
so what we've tallied represent the
results in all of the contests within
the election however
we have found discrepancies that we
can't explain
that would cast a doubt on whether or
not that margin of victory is solid and
that i could certify it to say that it's
definitely accurate
but is the discrepancy that that you
don't know if the person's vote was
counted or not counted
what is the discrepancy an example of a
discrepancy
is the when you sign in when you go to
vote in person
you sign in at the check-in table and
then they check your you know you're
given a card and led to a machine
if somebody fails to actually sign in
but is then led to a
a voter machine and votes
then that prince is going to be off by
one vote or if
that conversely if that person checks in
to vote
and that for some reason he decides he
doesn't want to hit the cast button
cast ballot button but he leaves and
doesn't tell a clerk what has happened
there's going to be a discrepancy there
in the number
of voters in each precinct and then the
number of votes recorded for
that precinct
but you so you would know the person who
not necessarily
like for example if they haven't signed
in we don't know who that extra person
is
necessarily sometimes we're able to do
enough investigation that we can figure
it out but not in these cases not these
particular ones that
mr gloria is reporting today if i could
follow up as well commissioner to maybe
clarify
in the course of a day at a particular
site you may have 50 voters who voted
precinct 1105.
there are two areas where we track that
activity
one is in the voter registration
database where we have our poll book
that signs voters in
that is that varies from time to time
what we tally into the system as a vote
does not change so if i end up with 50
votes
in my voter registration but then only
49
in my democracy suite or tabulation for
voting systems
i have a discrepancy and because there
were 50 votes
in that i can't determine exactly which
individual
it was affected by but i know that i'm
off and so we go through with every
single precinct by tally type
mail early voting and election day
and wherever there's a discrepancy it
should be a balance it should be 50 50
but when we have areas in a precinct
where it's 51 and 50
or 49 and 50 there's a discrepancy there
and so we search through our
documentation
to identify if the team leader has
identified
with paperwork to document that so that
we can explain it
if we don't have documentation then we
we can't make a determination as to
exactly
why that discrepancy occurred but we
know we have one
in the commission sea race i've
identified 139
that's the only race in the entire
uh election where we have any concern
related to the outcome
and it's because of the close margin
it's a district with 218 precincts
a margin of 10 is very difficult
to audit so to follow up on that if
there's a recount
the recount would still be the same
based on this discrepancy
not necessarily i couldn't guarantee
that it would come out 100
the same in 2016 we recounted over 800
000 ballots i believe it was and
at the end of the day we had a
discrepancy of four
so it was very tight and all those votes
that were cast it was only changed by
four
so that that's that's pretty tight as
far as
uh the process and and the fact that we
counted fairly accurately in that
election
i i can't tell you whether or not it
would be that close or there'd be a
wider margin
with a recount
but i'm saying this discrepancy would
not be identified by the recount because
the recount just counts
the 50 or the 49. precisely
according to statute we would count
those ballots in the exact same way we
counted him in for
this result so if i could ask the
attorney then
so what happens if if we if we have a
recount
uh and the same thing happens uh is
there
does the the winner have a recourse to
go to court or something
um the uh contestants always have the
ability to file a contest
rather than a recount and the contest
grounds are more broad
in this case there would be grounds for
a contest because there were
enough discrepancies discrepancies to
raise a question about the final vote
so rather than a recount it'd be more
likely that somebody would file a
contest because
as mr gloria said a recount's not going
to
solve those discrepancies for you
and just one question so if we do
certify today
this does not prevent requests for
recount or for
the other process you talked about well
if you
for the other races they could file
their contest
you can't file a contest of a race that
hasn't been certified because
technically
there's not a winner somebody hasn't
been declared a winner
there might be other legal avenues that
they could follow but not technically a
contest
so if we don't certify then are we then
saying
potentially we're going to ask for a
re-vote ourselves
that's what the board has done in the
past is set up a special election
just with those two candidates
to to rerun the election
can i ask who bears that cost do we at
the county is that what we did
i feel like there was a public
administrator that we did this for
it's not it's not the only time yeah
it's not an unusual practices
so but most recently did we did it with
the republican primary for
the public administrator
that was just in 2018.
we have to it it happens more likely in
assembly races because they're smaller
and then they're more likely to be close
than a bigger race but
commissioner jones ms miller what's the
statutory basis for uh
holding a special election i'm not
trying to understand that
in this case you could use um the same
statute that you cited
saying that for because there's a
catch-all clause there
you could determine that the will of the
voters had not been determined then hold
a special election
which statute specifically i believe you
decided
293.45
all these attorneys up here i feel
nervous
[Laughter]
okay
uh commissioner now thank you madam
chair um
while he's reviewing that ms miller
could you speak a little bit more to
where the proper forum for this to
proceed would be i understand
from your interpretation it is in this
body's ability
not to certify but if we don't it would
go through the court process
leaving candidates some options still to
protest the outcome
if you certified the results uh the
candidates
the losing candidate could file a
contest tomorrow
i believe that's a deadline is why i
mentioned tomorrow
so explain to me again what does that
mean so a contest
is going to court and essentially doing
the same sort of
analysis the judge would do the same
sort of analysis that you're doing today
and determine whether or not um the
person declared
the winner was was legally declared the
winner
okay uh commissioner uh weekly
and with that being said uh miss miller
the judge could declare
another race yes
or the judge could the judge just put it
back to us
for us to make a decision could it go
that way as well i'm just trying to
understand as well they would probably
direct the judge would probably say yes
it has to be another race but
the county commissioners have to call
that and the circumstances under which
it's called
that he wouldn't set the date for it
probably
commissioner gibson in the uh
in the motion it seems as though the
objective there
would be a special election
because you can't i mean unless the
candidate
who is behind gives up in a negotiation
and says i'm not going to
contest this otherwise the only way you
get
something that you can certify is by
taking
once you given you have to take into
account these discrepancies
uh would be if you held the election
again
so the question is what if
um do we have authority
to withhold a certification
and direct that there be a second vote
do we have that authority yes does it
require
that all the parties or the two parties
come together and
agree to that end or do we have
authority
plenary authority under the statutes
today
or in two weeks i don't know that it's
plenary authority but you don't have
authority
to declare that uh there's enough um
concerns about an election and a
particular raise that you won't
certify the result and direct staff to
um you guys have to call this special
election so we have that authority today
we don't need to wait for a judge to
decide that
that's correct
commissioner brown thank you a couple
questions
um joe the
discrepancies that you have referenced
are they common in all elections
commissioner brown yes there's no
election that goes without discrepancies
that are identified
in particular this time with such a
large male ballot
uh number that that number that i've
identified is actually
in the thousands of percent so it was
fairly accurate work it's
as a result of such a close margin of
victory
with 218 precincts and a margin of
victory of 10 it's
it's very difficult to to get through
that without having
the discrepancies being larger than the
margin of victory
so the past practice of
just regar disregarding discrepancies in
those races that the total number
would have no impact on the outcome that
has been standard practice at the county
and probably challenged on
a rare occasion that is correct
commissioner brown we we have for
as long as i can remember since i've
been here it has always been the
practice to go through and identify what
the discrepancies are and ensure
that the margin of victory surpasses
that so that you can certify
in the uh joe or mary on this one uh
questions that were brought up in the
earlier speakers reference to the letter
received
do we have the ability to or do we
have an obligation to look into those
accusations
uh and in the letter that you were sent
it it's certainly within the board's
discretion
there's not a lot of backup on there
you'd have to
create your own backup to support those
allegations or
perhaps that candidate would provide it
to you
okay and to commissioner sega bloom's
point
so a recount is going to serve no
purpose
to change what we know today is that
correct
other than perhaps four out of eight
hundred thousand that you referenced
it doesn't address the discrepancies no
it does not
we have the ability to recount and we
would recount in the same manner
according to statute as we read them
originally into the system but that
wouldn't change
the discrepancies that i've identified
madam chair and marianne correct me if
uh
i overstep here but i'd like to amend
the last portion of my amendment where i
indicated
at the next regular meeting with options
for the district c race only
i would say the register to come back at
the next regular
scheduled meeting with options for a
special election
in that race only would that be
allowable
can i ask for some clarification
commissioner tomorrow's our next regular
scheduled meeting so you don't mean
tomorrow right
how about how about the
first meeting in december is that
appropriate
okay and during that time again
i for one with less than
20 hours of briefings have so many
additional questions
if we could during that two-week time
frame
i'd meet with joe and council to find
out you know all the
other pieces that have come into this
and i'm guessing
uh would it be appropriate as was
mentioned earlier at the register reach
out to
both candidates to get some sense of
what a special election looks like from
a
programmable standpoint from a practical
standpoint from a timing standpoint
would that be appropriate that would
certainly be my recommendation
okay commissioner enough and then
commissioner jones commissioner brown i
was going to suggest if
if there is more briefings that's
required which i i think would be
helpful
do we then want to broaden the direction
to mr gloria
rather than make it more specific
that was my earlier motion but i i got
the sense that we are focusing in on
the only thing that could happen um
that that might be the will of the board
i just raised the question if there
if there is more briefings required or
perhaps you're meaning more briefings
specifically on
uh what a future subsequent election
would look like
okay commissioner jones i think i'm sure
nrs 293 387
requires us to canvas complete our
canvas today so
i guess in terms of reviewing
discrepancies before
the december meeting do we even have
discretion ms miller to do anything
other than hold a
special election if we don't certify
today
i'm not aware of any other options so we
either
certify today or we don't and it has to
go to a special election
that's my understanding okay so we're
not going to look at discrepancies
because looking at discrepancies isn't
going to matter right
[Music]
christopher jones uh when you initially
say this you said i thought
that you interpreted state law to say
our only obligation was to certify
um is that that's your legal
interpretation of what's what's
what's at stake right yes i'm not
counsel for the board though
i know but i'm saying that's it there's
there's certain arguments we made that
that
that we don't have the discretion to say
we're going to call an election we're
just saying
certified
anything else uh commissioner any other
commissioners
kaiser gibson of course when
this when the phone started ringing last
week
and uh people from both sides um
were reaching out the
first thing that occurred to me was this
is easy we'll just do a recount and
that'll be the end of it
the this additional complication in my
estimation
elevates it to a place where the
transcendent importance of
the commission and it's in
this institution the county
mr gloria's reputation and the entire
election department's reputation
in my estimation is affected by the
action that we take
and i believe that
the way that we address it
as imperfect as it may be
may apparently only is to
do a special election
so i guess for that reason since there
really are no other viable options we
can either
wait and some court tells us to do
a special election or we can get out of
the way
and get something going so the people in
district c
can find a new
commissioner and it's disappointing
that there have been things like the
ones that are described i'm
i'm i imagine there are other things
um that is that have happened and were
any of the ballots returned and not
readable marked in a way that is
confusing
did that happen i don't know how you do
that but
are there any other things is there any
voter
negligence in the way that these
discrepancies
get characterized in the hundreds of
thousands of ballots commissioner that
were reviewed there are issues with
ballots
that's why we have a duplication board
that can take a look at the ballot and
as long as we follow the
prescribed determinations that
we've reviewed with our county d.a
they have the ability to duplicate a
ballot and then we can get it into the
system
the system performed relatively
flawlessly
because we are able to review the
document and make sure that it's not in
a condition that would damage the
machine
so there were many instances where the
icc scanner was unable to read ballots
but we did
see ballots that were identified we did
see ballots that were damaged
uh that had to be duplicated to run into
the system but
nothing that would reach to the level
that we call it a discrepancy that's
just the normal course of an election
so the the work that would be done
for any race that was on this ballot has
been done
everything has been reviewed and
what we're suggesting here today has no
implication
or bears not at all on outcomes in any
other race
it is only in this race now we had
a couple up here i i went back and
looked at the report
it looks like there are several thousand
um
votes different in the case of some of
the people whose names were mentioned as
candidates who
are seeking relief and and maybe there's
something they can do but um i see this
so dramatically differently from any of
the rest of them because of the number
and you've isolated it down to 139 i
think you said
ballots i and i just don't think we have
any option i think that the credibility
of everything that we
do is something that can be
affirmed by simply doing that rather
than waiting for some court
to tell us how to conduct our business
so i
i i think that's where i come down but
thank you very much madam chair
okay commissioner jones what is the
estimated cost of a special election in
this case
that would depend on how we hold the
election commissioner so
i will have those costs with me when i
present to you on what the options are
and if there are any discussions between
now
and the next commission meeting i will
be prepared to have those numbers
if a ms miller if a contest were if we
certified today and a contest were filed
and a judge
were to not not agree with our
certification or canvas of the result
would the cost then be born by
mr anthony not the cost of the election
um i think they can recover court costs
against the other parties to the contest
but if a
judge orders a new election the
jurisdiction
bears the cost of that election thank
you
okay uh commissioner ms miller could you
could you speak a little bit more to the
eventuality that
uh the court would rule uh or your
estimation that a court would rule
that a re-vote needs to occur i i don't
think because of the nature of the
discrepancies
that any court presented with these
discrepancies
um would be comfortable saying that
with the results really reflect the will
of the voters in commission see
it's just such a close race we're unable
to go back
and find out which way those votes went
one way or the other
a court would not be able to do that in
any of that too so the court would
really be in very similar situation
to what the commissioners are today
okay uh can you show around you want to
reset your amended motion
thank you madam chair i would like to
make the following motion that we
accept the canvas of the vote and
certify the election results with the
exception
of county commission district c the
commission has received into
individual briefings and over the last
24 hours
and some of the discrepancies outlined
by the register
indicate that the discrepancies surpass
the narrow margin of victory in that
race
calling into question the validity of
the election results
in just the district c race i would like
to ask the register to come back at the
next
regular meeting no i take that back
i would like to register to come back
the first meeting in december
with options for a special election in
the district c
race only and
submit a copy of the abstract of votes
cast to the nevada secretary of state
per ab4
okay you've heard the motion any other
discussion
cnn please cast your vote
that motion passes
can i can i ask a question mr gloria um
outside of that long discussion we just
said
so what happens to the people that voted
twice i hope that we're going to go
after them
correct if we can prove that it was
egregious and on purpose
that would need to be an investigation
done where they interview the
individuals we definitely have the
evidence
to provide that they did in fact vote
twice so
i can't tell you exactly in each
scenario what might or might not happen
but we'll definitely be submitting them
to the secretary of state
and then how long does that process i
mean i just would like you to put us
back in the loop because i just want to
make sure that we
we um keep up with the integrity of
elections
and we remind folks the importance of
doing it the right way one sure
at your request madam chair i'll be sure
to stay abreast of what's going on in
the investigation
once we submit okay okay
so um miss king does that conclude us
except for the public yes it does
manager okay this is the second time set
aside for public comment anybody wishing
to speak on public comment
cnn we are going to go ahead and close
the public comment and we are adjourned